part of the furniture you haven't got
much to spare who cares what I've only
got yeah alright good so um how was
Australia it was nice yeah yeah no I've
never been down there yeah we're right
they call they call lobsters bugs out
there yeah they do while they're in the
bed of resident [ __ ] up about animals
I'm just talking about Australia why do
we call them bugs cuz they yeah I'm tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing shut up Brian will you fight
Lisa give a [ __ ]
well well kind of see what I said to
[ __ ] Chris D'Elia
Oh serious man yeah ooh who's that
listen if you're feeling froggy you got
a head and leap all right now you're
looking for trouble
and you're being disrespectful downing
water table hey trouble here okay drop
here
I'm pay this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]